-Over the years,
one of my favorite things
about having you on the show --
You have had many odd jobs.
And yet every time you´re here,
I discover a new one about you.
You worked at a carnival?
-Yes.
As a matter of fact,
so did the guy in that clip,
Smokey Putnam,
the guy with the elephants.
He didn´t work at a carnival,
but he --
Anyway, he worked
for the circus.
But we go to the carnival
to try and find him.
-Did that bring back
memories for you?
-Uh, it did.
I worked at a carnival
for a very short time
when I was quite young.
I ran the Whack-The-Cats.
-Uh-huh.
Is that like Whack-A-Mole?
-No, nothing like it at all.
I mean, you´ve seen it.
The cats are, like, lion faces.
-Okay.
-And they´re fabric.
It´s about this big.
And, then, behind the fabric
is a little board
that´s about this wide.
-Uh-huh.
-Soft on the sides, like that.
-Got it.
-And then you´re given
baseballs, and you throw them
to try and knock
the cat faces down.
Whack-The-Cats.
But, of course, you miss so much
because it´s actually
a very thin board
behind the larger face.
-Oh, I see. It tricks you into
throwing at the soft part.
-Yeah, I mean, you can´t -- You
have to hit the middle of it.
Anyway, I did the Whack-The-Cats
at this carnival.
I even roped a friend of mine
into working at the carnival,
as well.
He worked the fishing well.
And it´s not called
a fishing well.
What is it? A wishing well
maybe or something?
Anyway, you fish for things.
But anyway --
[ Laughter ]
It was an abysmal carnival.
-Really?
-It was so bleak. But, also,
I worked the day shift.
And so --
I think probably the night
is the better shift
to work there maybe.
-For carnivals? Sure, yeah.
-I mean, I guess.
It´s not like
you get tips, though.
But it´s just busier,
so you pass the time.
Like, I did teach myself
how to juggle,
which I no longer
know how to do.
It´d be great if I said
that I did that
and then I could come out here
and juggle for you all.
But I can´t. But I can´t
even bring that to the table.
All I have
is the bathroom story.
Anyway --
And a clip.
-Yeah. You brought the clip.
Thank you.
-I brought the clip.
Someone else sent the clip.
-Okay. Gotcha.
You didn´t even do that.
-I didn´t even do that.
-When did you know your time
at the carnival was done?
Did you ever say,
"This isn´t the life for me"?
-[ Laughs ] Oh, yes.
I used to drive up there
with my buddy
in my little VW Bug
that had no floor.
And we would go there,
and we´d --
Anyway, I would be standing
there, and I´d be there for --
You know, there´ be a half-hour
in between people coming
to the Whack-The-Cats.
It was not a very popular thing.
-And then you just got close
to the cats, I´m imagining.
-And the prizes stunk, sort of.
Anyway, but I was
standing there one day,
and all of a sudden,
I see the guy
who ran the ride
that was next to me.
And the ride was one of those --
I don´t know --
Tilt-A-Whirl or Cups --
something spinning.
And it was next to me there.
And I used to actually
pick him up hitchhiking
to come to the carnival.
-So this place
obviously paid real well.
-It was so --
It was so bleak.
Anyway, one day,
I was staying there --
So I had gotten to know the guy,
you know,
pick him up hitchhiking,
and all of a sudden,
he´s walking by.
This is after I´ve only been
working there a few weeks.
And he´s walking by,
and he´s just got
this sort of demoralized look
and sort of hanging his head
and wandering up towards,
you know, the office,
which was a shed.
And headed that way.
And I said,
"Everything all right?"
He said,
"Kid fell off the ride."
[ Laughter ]
I don´t even know
if they heard that.
I said it too quietly.
-A kid fell off the ride.
-Kid fell off the ride.
Anyway, and it just --
He said it --
The way he said it,
I just thought,
"I got to get
the hell out of here."
I mean, the way he said it
was just like, "Again."
-Yeah.
Not shock.
-No, not --
-He´s been worn down.
-It was about the paperwork
or the report
or whatever the thing, you know,
that he was going to
have to fill out.
-He had to mark --
"Who fell off the ride? Kid."
-It was a really brutal job.
I didn´t last very long.
Only, you know,
a couple months or less.
Like a month
or month and a half.
But I had so many, you know,
odd jobs and manual-labor jobs
and ones that were
really hard --
like, you know,
loading and unloading
freight cars
and tractor-trailer trucks.
I worked in a meat-packing
plant, unloading sides of beef.
-If you had to choose --
-But that job was so
calcifyingly boring.
It was like retail. Retail --
-But it´s so funny
because I feel like
people write books about
working at a carnival.
No one writes -- They´re
working at the meat place.
But you´re saying
the meat job was better.
-Well, I was busy.
-Yeah.
-I was working at a carnival
that people weren´t coming to.
And it was also during the day.
And no one´s there.
And doesn´t a carnival
live at night?
It was like --
It´s actually like my job,
television.
You know,
I got into this business
´cause it was a night job.
-Yeah.
-And then it turned out
that it wasn´t.
-Yeah.
-And that was a rude awakening.
-So you got ripped off.
-No pun intended.
-One of these days, you´re
going to find a job you like,
and I really hope that --
-No, no, no.
I do. I love my job.
But I was counting on
the later hour.
I´m not a morning person.
-Yeah.
-And -- This wouldn´t be bad.
But you show up
in the morning, don´t you?
-Yeah, I do show up
in the morning, yeah.
-Count me out.
-Okay.
-Well, please
come back again, though.